je m'appelle Emanuel j'ai 17 ans et
j'ai tué ma mère elle a perdu la vie pour
ça alors que tu prenais ton premier souffle elle a
pris son dernier ils ont essayé de la ranimer
elle était partie et j'étais ici
elle n'a pas mentionné qu'elle
je cherchais une baby-sitter mais je ne
pense à personne du haut de ma tête
je le ferai quand nous commencerons je lui
parlerai demain
salut que se passe-t-il si le bébé se réveille tu la
berces en arrière-et-  et tu lui
parles parce qu'elle aime la mort elle aime
qu'on lui parle parfois je ne veux juste
pas être mère je veux juste appuyer sur un
bouton je continue ma journée elle n'a
jamais eu de mère et je pense  que cela
a créé un désir en elle
tu devrais porter ce regard sur toi
belle elle n'est pas ta mère
elle ne ressemble en rien à ta mère tu
m'entends je ne veux juste pas qu'elle interprète mal
ton penchant pour elle
ne pense pas
qu'il soit un petit ami pour toi,
ce serait plutôt sympa, mais ça ne peut pas être les
trois  nous pour toujours et à jamais je meurs juste de
manger ce bébé en
ce moment
eh bien
je pense qu'elle commence à m'aimer
comme elle t'aime c'est comme ça que ça se sent donc
j'ai toujours imaginé que ça se sentirait